I can't even believe that this is only
your second album full length yeah which
is crazy because Jesus it's been a long
journey man Vic mens is here peace peace
thank you for having me yes sir man it
is kind of crazy to think like uh I know
you just did like um the internet tape
in its entirety with with chance uh was
it two shows you did
second show was in LA on September 21.
okay so that's still coming um
how many years ago is that 10 years now
that was 10 years this year yeah crazy
September 30th will be the 10 year how
you feeling right now though man you've
had it feeling good man you feeling good
feeling super blessed man just grateful
inspired motivated
a lot of clarity focused right you know
what I'm saying I like you've had one of
the more interesting Journeys in rap
you've been obviously you know a part of
a amazing group that I feel like kind of
kicked down the doors of a lot of what
you know that early Chicago wave that
you and chance are a part of shot the
kids these days
um fast forward because he says who's on
tour with Asher Roth was that when I
first yeah when I first met you you were
on tour with that wrong you guys came
and freestyle at the radio station man
was that Phoenix that was the middle of
the night too it's like after it was
after the show yeah Phoenix we was
mobbed up yeah who else was there was uh
Chuck English yeah talk English was
there too maybe buddy
I know buddy was on the tour buddy from
L.A yeah buddy dude I don't know if he
was I didn't even understand I didn't
even know about him back then so that's
crazy because I come to think of it like
he was definitely with us and I don't
think I all the way put it together
later down the line when I reconnected
with Buddy in the studio with Pharrell
you know because he was signing for real
for some time and um
but I had first gotten to know him on
tour with Asher he was just like you
know they're crazy Young Homie you know
I mean always smoking and [__] walking
[Laughter]
I said Jazz tour that was passing Jazz
shout out to Ashley Roth shout out to
Ashley Roth That's my boy man great guy
um but you just had such a crazy journey
man I mean you know obviously
um to only have
like you have to me classic bodies of
work but to like actually think like
damn you really only have two
full-length albums like this is your
second one coming out on the 15th
um why Victor and why why now
I called it Victor because it's a very
personal album and I think it represents
me like as a human being and that's
that's me before nicknames you know what
I'm saying and I had a revelation about
my name when I was
doing mushrooms in the woods that sounds
amazing always a great time you know I
took my moms to do mushrooms in the
woods amazing recently that was fire
nice and I had a revelation about my
name just in that like
I realized man it's so much in the name
and oftentimes the names that we're
given almost predict the lives that we
lead you know I was named Victor
um in honor of my most famous ancestor
on my father's side okay my father's
from Ghana my entire family lives over
there
and the most famous ancestor in his
lineage his name bro from
you know many centuries ago and he
fought against British Invasion into
Africa and um
I was named Victor in honor of his
victories and I was sitting there in the
woods and I'm just thinking about it and
I was realizing man like
he fought for freedom all those hundreds
of years ago and I was just named that
and fast forward here I am like freeing
people from prison and helping get
people off death row and it was almost
like just a revelation that this path
was laid out for me and I think even in
reflecting upon
the ups and downs the struggles the the
fight you know I mean just a sense of
perseverance is that like
I'm programmed
to win I'm programmed to live through
things because I am Victor I'm the
Victor you know what I'm saying but to
be the Victor you you have to have a
fight you got to have a fight to win you
know then you have to have a fight to
win and I would characterize
um you know my time and music in the
music industry uh much in that way you
know I mean it has been a battle I think
our first battle though as human beings
is with ourself right you know so
pre-dating coming into music predating
me meeting bootleg cab when I was a
teenager you know that battle with
myself were you on that tour I was 17.
Jesus Christ I have more of a beer then
than that for sure and you had a lot
more hair yeah a scruffy yeah for real
though I don't think I changed my
clothes that whole tour like crazy it's
on YouTube
um
yeah you know predating all those things
that battle with self existed and I
think coming into music I say that
whatever you got going on is just going
to be magnified you know what I'm saying
so the talent the genius the Charisma
the
um creativity magnified also the
insecurities you know the ups and downs
are on the microscope for the uh the the
depression the addiction like the
addictive personality all those things
it's just magnified and coming in to
this industry that is so dog eat dog
chew you up and spit you out for sure um
I think everything was just everything
was just magnified so it's really been a
fight but I named the album that because
the album is like really a story of
redemption and me expressing a lot of
gratitude for being able to live through
that fight because a lot of young
rappers don't get that chance